look how about something a bit different
here um
not that this is okay so check this guy
out be on the lookout for this guy guys
all right
if you're in the new york area
well new this morning police are
searching for the man who robbed an
armored truck in the bronx video shows
the suspect running off his arms filled
with bags containing
200 okay hold on 200 000
how did this happen because like the
whole point the whole armored truck
thing
is supposed to be super secure like
supposed to have armed guards and
there's always supposed to be somebody
right next to the money at all times
there's always two in a truck yeah it's
very how did this happen and trust me i
know
because i've seen many many of these
trucks in my day and i've been in many
scenarios where one pulled in
sometimes in a shady area and trust me
it's been a fantasy my whole life
to have that moment i don't think i
could resist if there was a moment where
it's just there and you're like
you know what i think about uh groundhog
day
when he just times it he times it he
just grabs the money but i've always
just wondered like you know if you just
get that guy that's like just not paying
attention for two minutes and you can go
just grab one stack out and slip away
but
like it never happens that way any time
i've been around an armored car it's
always
one stops starts pumping gas the other
one's in there's always one that stays
in the truck
of course it's bulletproof the other one
comes out has a shotgun and you're like
this isn't going to be what like
did how do you just do that in new
york's you know what i think it is
honestly
kovit has probably made a lot of people
lazy you're right because there's not
people out about and everything so
you're like yeah whatever
it's the suspect running filled with
bags containing
two oh look man i am i was gonna say the
same thing
i don't give a [ __ ] if you rob from
these banks i don't care i wouldn't do
it obviously
but good for him [ __ ] them [ __ ] these
banks
take from them take from them all you
want find ways to manipulate them
they're pieces of [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] that they do and the [ __ ]
that they get away with because you know
what hasn't been shut down during covert
banks banks aren't shut down all of them
are open
all the money while they [ __ ] scam
you and while they take your [ __ ]
home away
and when you when you go ahead and call
your bank when you got your loan out for
your mortgage you go look i couldn't pay
my mortgage
covet i didn't have a job they're gonna
take your home anyway
they don't care [ __ ] them this guy
american hero he is a hero
like yeah i um years ago when i was um
when i did one of those you know i was
getting whatever my salary check every
week at one of my jobs
and i uh i went to the [ __ ] bank it
was a small check it was like 480 bucks
after taxes so i go to the [ __ ] bank
and i needed to pull cash out
immediately so it's one of those where
you deposit like
80 bucks of your 480 dollar check and i
need the 400 cash
and they gave me the 400 cash whatever
ended up depositing the entire check
and it was like the best feeling in the
world because
like you know i would never steal from a
little old lady or like you know
somebody that
if like i'm at a store and a sh like a
clerk
is like [ __ ] up their change i know
that's going to come out of their pay
like
when it was a bank i was like nice [ __ ]
these people
rob gavin goes haven't you guys ever
seen the town hitting trucks is easy
step one
none costumes that's what it was this
guy
dressed like no none can i can we can
you see how
his run isn't exciting searching for the
man he robbed an armored truck in the
bronx video shows the suspect running
off his arms
200 000 it happened yesterday afternoon
on east 100 he looks a lot like the guy
that punched rick moranis
i like how they have no footage of this
guy they have one clip that they have to
keep playing on a loop
i hope he gets away gerard avenue in the
concourse section
the man pushed the armored car worker
who was unloading cash from the truck
before taking off he just pushed the guy
that was you know it's great you know
it's true how many movies have you
watched
where they have like a [ __ ] board on the
wall and they have like the strings and
like okay here's what we're going to do
we're going to time it perfectly online
yeah guys
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this game we need two getaway cars
they got to be oh we got to have weapons
they got to have all the serial numbers
filed off they're gonna be unmarked
this guy's named phil he takes his
coffee break every day at exactly 1 45
p.m
all he did was push the guy to the
ground and run away with the money
listen you won't be bringing the guns
with you they'll be waiting at the job
there's a dead drop behind a dumpster
right where he has his coffee every day
you're going to get the guns
you got to be real calm it's going to be
daylight yeah there's a whole plan and
then this the guy was like
hey man uh do you know what time it is
i'm at corkboard i don't know why i said
cockpit
he's just like hey excuse me uh do you
have the time and he's like it's about
three
he just ran he just shoves him and runs
like i can't believe that worked and
somebody says
somebody said was the guard a [ __ ]
turtle he just couldn't get back
up he's just on his shell
that's so funny though that he just did
the old excuse me
sir do you know where 56th street is oh
yeah you're gonna want to go
just ran away like holy [ __ ] by the way
they are going to catch this guy and
he's going to do serious time
and he's probably going to get a
full-born full-blown assault charge for
pushing him on watch
these bankers oh yeah these bankers
always find their man
very rare you get away with [ __ ] like
this
they take it personal cash from the
truck before taking off with bags
it is 452 new information after two
children were snatched
okay well i don't really care about that
uh
no offense i live in new york uh
hmm but yeah they're gonna definitely
probably catch this guy because
they don't they'll they'll put so much
effort into finding this guy while like
75
just go completely like completely
uncaught